même les enfants m'appellent vêti
demande toujours appelé ne pas pas aussi
oui ils ont toujours ils ont toujours
appelé roger betty est ce que betty
c'est votre vrai prénom une simple se
donner c'est un diminutif d'elisabeth
qui est mon prénom mais on ne m'a jamais
appelé autrement que betty d'accord
toujours appelé betty que aussi loin que
je me souvienne les parents m'appeler
betty et c'est resté tout nu ce soit à
l'école que ce soit mes élèves que ce
soit au bureau on a toujours appelé
betty
mannequin à la réunion chanteuse de
variété et de folklore betty ebrard a
été l'une des figures illustres du monde
artistique locale de ses parents elle à
se cultiver puis transmettre à l'eau si
le sens de la musique et du rythme une
passion encore intacte d'aujourd'hui
pour cet informaticien de métier
puisqu'elle enseigne désormais la danse
et produit des spectacles avec une
histoire c'est une époque pas si
lointaine qu'elle nous fait partager
depuis quand vous évoluez dans le monde
artistique
ça remonte quand même loin parce que
j'avais 11 ans la dernière fois je la
fais la première fois je me souviens
c'était
une sorte de spectacle conte organisée
dans le cadre des fêtes de noël et on
m'a demandé de chanter avec
monsieur qui jouait de la guitare et on
chantait l'homme et l'enfant à l'époque
c'était dit constantine et une petite
fille qui chantait et je faisais
l'enfant le fait d'être la fille d'un
personnage célèbre à la réunion est ce
que ça vous a aidé quelque part dans
votre évolution
ce qui m'a aidé c'est le fait que aussi
bien mon père que ma mère était dans le
domaine de la musique de la danse parce
qu'il dansait tous les deux très bien
ça m'a aidé ou dans ce sens mais sans ça
mon père n'a pas cherché à me pousser ou
à me freiner d'ailleurs
non je pense excepté une suite logique
que je fasse de la musique de la chanson
de la danse comme des parents est ce que
vous vous transmettez cette passion en
vos enfants oui parce que les deux vies
chantent dansent comme moi ses pairs
il y en a une qui a fait beaucoup de
mannequinat dans l'île un epic
maintenant me remplace dans le groupe
folklorique
c'est l'aîné et la seconde sandrine qui
chante dans le groupe zone qui a été
également mannequin aussi bien de ce
plan local que à paris et qui maintenant
chante également
j'ai commencé à chanter uniquement du
brésilien parce que j'ai toujours été
fasciné par la musique brésilienne et
j'ai commencé avec ça tout mon
répertoire a été uniquement brésilien et
après ça a été de la variété et la
variété ça a été beaucoup très très
grande partie nicole croisille
en tant que chanteuse puisque je
chantais j'ai très souvent fait la
première partie d'artistes qui venait à
la réunion pour se produire et quels
souvenirs vous avez 2 c
très bon souvenir parce qu
automatiquement on est on est en contact
avec eux
c'est un peu un monde qu'on croit
inaccessible lorsqu'on est dans une île
et puis finalement quand on les côtoie
ce sont des gens comme nous vous avez eu
l'occasion d'exercer votre passion ça
des scènes métropolitaine racontez nous
un petit peu comment ça s'est passé
alors beaucoup moins souvent sur la
scène des tripolitaines parce que bien
que j'ai vécu toute mon enfance et mon
adolescence en france
je suis ici pratiquement depuis l'âge de
20 ans et après j'ai vécu ici je me suis
mariée ici j'ai vécu ici et sur les
salles métropolitaine et étrangère
puisque je chantais avec le conte
folklorique et on a chanté un peu
partout ça s'est produit lors de voyages
ou lors de tournées avec le groupe
folklorique parce que les chansons que
vous a marqué le plus non en fait y en a
plein
mais il y en a une effectivement parce
que elle est là elle a un passé je
trouve qu'il est superbe parce que c'est
benoît boulard qui avait lancé ce ségala
l'époque qui est le sait qu'à piquer et
que j'ai rechanter mois ensuite avec le
groupe folklorique qui est sur le cd du
coffret clics
vous arrive de sortir quand même ça
m'arrive encore oui
ça ne vous manque pas trop simple
ça me manque un peu parce que j'aurai
presque voulu en faire mon métier
c'est un désir caché qu'est ce qui vous
a arrêté
est bien c'est que je pouvais je pense
ne pas pouvoir faire carrière à la
réunion donc j'ai préféré faire d'autres
choses qui me plaisait tout autant
d'ailleurs
bien il va complètement à l'extérieur et
quelqu'un je trouve que c'est plus un
artiste local
c'est beaucoup plus difficile il faut se
battre et bon c'est pas tout le monde
qui réussit forcément où on marche sur
les deux plans et ça peut marcher c'est
le tas de certaines personnes comme
jacqueline farreyrol n'est entièrement
ici je pense que c'est dû est-ce que vos
filles viennent régulièrement prendre
conseil avec nous on se voit
régulièrement prendre conseils d'un
j'espère que dans mon éducation de toute
façon j'ai essayé deux des leurs
de leur donner l'essentiel c'est qu'à
cliquer dès l'enfance dès l'enfance déjà
lorsque j'étais enceinte de deux j'ai
continué la chanson donc elles ont
appris la musique dans mon ventre parce
que vos parents ont été sévères avec
vous mes parents étaient sévères dégâts
notre et j'ai fait la même chose que mes
fils était dire qu'à l'époque je
trouvais pas ça bien du tout quand
j'étais enfant mais après je les ai
remerciés parce que je me suis rendu
compte que ça m'avait beaucoup ça
ne va pas non c'est pas tellement maman
était plus sévère que papa je pense mais
papa était très juste il était rigoureux
juste mais peuvent forcément sévère et
monsieur auguste de groupe qui est votre
père ne vous a pas inculqué ça tandis
que ça la politique
il m'a pas pousser en tout cas il a
parlé à la maison il n'en parlait très
souvent parce qu'en fait lui il en a
toujours fait
mais moi personnellement je ne suis pas
très politique parce qu'il avait une
devise qu'il s'est passé dans sa famille
je crois que ça a été ce que j'ai fait
moi avec mes enfants c'était la rigueur
et patrick brevets avec soi même et avec
les autres
on est sur une île donc en vase clos et
il est très difficile d'évoluer parce
qu'on n'a pas ou n'a pas les mutations
nécessaires pour aller et pour faire
mieux pour aller au dessus pour faire
mieux j'étais dans le même cas lorsque
je faisais du sport j'ai été numéro 1 et
pour faire pour rester à la tête ça a
été très dur parce que j'avais personnes
- à battre mais le tennis je suis venu
très tard et j'ai grimpé très vite en
fait et gp championne de la réunion des
85 ap exane a été complètement
vous avez style c'est ailleurs les plus
particulièrement dans la danse dans la
danse c'est une suite logique à votre
carrière d'artiste
je sais pas si on peut parler de suite
parce que j'ai toujours dansé c'est vrai
j'ai toujours dansé jeune enseigne est
pas alors que maintenant je conseille et
c'est qu'elle chante danse que
l'enseigné dans une société c'est à dire
valse tango paso chacha sont
toutes ses enfants quand est-ce qu'on
devrait trouver le temps pour vous
former
alors je me suis formée en fait en
métropole et en travaillant ici puisque
pour passer les examens je ne pouvais
pas le faire ici c'est pas possible ça
ne pouvait se faire qu'en métropole j'ai
passé mes examens avec la fédération
française des sports de danses et ça se
fait sur deux ans
j'étais en métropole donc à plusieurs
reprises pour le préparer pour préparer
mes examens je les ai travaillé ici et
je les ai pas c'est finalement en
métropole
oui est ce que vous faites une
différence entre la danse et la chanson
je fais la différence dans l'expression
elle même mais pas dans la c'est un art
de toute façon et pour moi l'art ça se
rejoint d'une façon ou d'une autre est
ce qu'on peut dire que la danse complète
toute façon tout à fait
faire
en dehors de mes cours
j'organise des stages fait venir un
professeur d'afrique du sud
régulièrement la réunion pour organiser
des stages
il ya un suivi comme je vous dis jamais
ton quand même beaucoup de temps parce
que c'est très difficile d'expliquer aux
autres ce qu'on aime si on aime c'est
pas très difficile
certains apprennent plus difficilement
que d'autres mais
lorsque vous voyez les progrès et
l'assiduité de certains à vouloir
apprend c'est la récompense professeur
très motivés
secret difficile de choisir les gens
pour le spectacle n'importe qui à la
limite peut faire un spectacle à partir
du moment où il est motivé où il a envie
de le faire dans mon prochain spectacle
là j'ai aussi bien des élèves qui ont
quatre années de danse qu'un élève qui a
commencé cette année
seulement il est motivé il veut le faire
et il apprend un peu plus difficilement
parce que les autres savent de quoi je
parle et lui il est en train d'apprendre
donc il sait pas toujours de quoi je
parle mais il apprend ils avancent plus
difficilement plus doucement mais il
avance et c'est super qu'il y ait ces
deux niveaux ou c3 où ces quatre niveaux
là et semble qu est ce que vous pensez
des nouvelles musiques laura etc lorsque
j'entends ce que fait le groupe atp l'as
moi j'aime beaucoup mélange le rap avec
le maloya mais je trouve ça super ces
évolutions il faut tout les choses
évoluer le club folklore qu'on garde
tout ce qui a été notre folklore c'est
bien mais qu'il évolue c'est aussi bien
maintenant il ya simplement
commune donne et tu recevras c'est tout
c'est l'idée qui passe avant d'enfoncer
j'ai quelque chose à donner je vais le
donner avec beaucoup d'amour et ça
passera tout seul à partir du moment où
il ya glamour ça passe tout seul